Hello
Freak bitches.
Because I think the ability to
communicate and open debate is why we've
advanced to the point we're at in the
first place.
The suppressing of that is almost always
someone who has a bad idea and they're
trying to shelter.
So when you see people that are chasing
after someone because they're trying to
communicate about something like you
were just doing it super d respectfully,
what,
when when you see that what you have is
a bunch of people that are trying to
defend a bad idea and defend it with
aggression,
you're right.
And,
and,
but if the more you kind of become a
mirror image of whatever,
whatever they're projecting,
you reinforce them in their position as
well as from doing other stories about
extreme religious beliefs like the
Westboro Baptist church.
I know from people who I met who were in
the church when I made my documentary
and then subsequently left that,
uh,
what short circuits their beliefs,
what allows them to see something bigger
than what they're in is when you treat
them with kindness and instead of
shouting back at them or hurling abuse
back,
which just reinforces their view of you
as an enemy of God or suppressive or
however they characterize it,
if you actually behave decently and
attempt to robustly present your
position but in a respectful way and
with a kind of coming from a place of
caring and empathy as opposed to,
um,
so since soria so hostile attitude that
actually,
um,
it can be a much more effective.
Absolutely knows what it's being humane.
I saw this pregnant woman on the l train
in New York,
but she was one season.
One of those was she didn't,
she just looked like her stomach was
bigger.
It,
nothing else affect like perfect makeup,
just dressed nice in a nice dress.
She didn't have a wedding ring on.
I wanted to,
I just wanted to ask her if everything
was okay.
If she was with the dope,
like she was so beautiful at cab looking
at it.
I know she felt me looking at it.
I probably waited her out.
She was so beautiful.
I started picturing myself arguing with
the real thing.
Father,
five years from now,
Huh?
I started pitching myself on the train.
Holding hands are there.
I started pitching myself five years
from now at the yelling at this dude
outside the house in Jersey.
Hey Dude,
you had your chance.
Yeah.
You like your county uses a sperm donor.
You're looking at her beautiful real.
Dot.
I'm the real dad.
You calculating the potential for future
joy,
being with that person with perfect bone
structure,
you will let me to take a chance and put
your whole life into it.
How was this the errands?
Just like,
oh my God,
look at it was you okay?
Huh?
Hey Baby.
You okay?
That's what I was saying.
Okay.
Who He'd say I'm her here.
Go.
If I'm looking down,
I'm just shaking my head.
I'm just like,
every now and then I just go like this
one hands.
You want to try it?
Oh,
come on.
The train.
Hey,
it good though,
Dude.
I know,
I look good.
See,
this is the thing,
I wouldn't even if you go ahead and me
on a train,
if I don't have anything organic,
I was,
I,
something crazy happened.
Oh Dude,
I'm not asking for real life.
This isn't law and order.
I know.
This is like,
come on.
All right.
Okay.
I'm the girl ready to go.
Sorry.
I just accidentally put my face in your
pussy.
Oh,
who's baby is that in there?
Cause he in the baby's life.
Do you put your long life?
Hi,
I'm financially stable.
Not quite a Mosley,
but I'm getting there.
And on that note,
ladies and gentlemen,
this podcast is a wrap.
Yet I've got family members,
uh,
and again,
this is not my family of my wife or
kids,
but the family that I was born into that
have never apologized about anything
because they come from a cultural
landscape where to apologize to your
child,
to somebody younger is to lose face.
A parent is always right.
And,
I mean,
that might work when you're too,
but when you're both now adults,
I think you could sort of have to get
out of that and realize that we all make
mistakes and we all have to own up to
them.
We all have to apologize honestly,
when we make a mistake.
And yet some people it's super unhealthy
and it's unhealthy for the person who
doesn't admit they make the mistake too.
Because then it puts you in this
position of being in denial of what you
know to be the truth,
right?
You're going to run around pretending
that you were right all along when you
know in your head that you weren't
wrong.
So it diminishes your own personal
opinions about yourself.
Right?
I'm sorry you're not sorry.
Ready on,
on this exact point.
Okay.
So I'm having a chat with a family
member,
an older family member of my,
for my family as the problem person.
This is,
this is one of the key problem for
people in my family.
And,
uh,
he said something to the effect of,
Oh,
you know,
those ancient Greeks,
uh,
those Christians were really,
antisemetic where I come up with the
exact details.
I said,
oh,
well,
you know,
I'm,
I'm sorry,
I don't mean to correct you,
but,
uh,
those ancient Greeks were not Christian.
As a matter of fact,
the way we mark that,
as we say,
bce,
before common era or BC before Christ.
So by definition,
those guys were marked as not being
Christian.
So when he's now faced with sort of
historical evidence that suggests that
he was wrong.
What'd you think?
He does it?
It's so grotesque that I'm not even sure
you can guess what he did.
I don't want to guess.
So he basically says no,
that's right.
That's what I said.
I said that they weren't Christian.
You said that they were Christian,
so he looks at you in the face.
That's,
that's called,
if,
if you'd allow me saying on air,
that's mind fucking right.
Yeah.
He looks at you in the face.
He knows that,
you know,
but he has enough in Arabic.
You say what?
Huh?
It's the,
it's this kind of pathological pride.
Right.
Fuck you right.
I'm going to look at you.
Right.
So rather than saying,
Oh gee,
I didn't know that.
Thanks for correcting me.
He flips what our original points of
this agreements was
there.
You can talk to that dude.
You've got to cut that guy loose.
Well,
maybe I have,
oh,
maybe you have,
I like how you said that.
Long story short for listeners,
uh,
Joe was kind enough to,
I was interviewing Sam Harris for my
podcast and Sam was like,
we really should just do more than just
a one on one because ordinarily my
podcast is about as a panel of people,
a bunch of people sitting around and
talking about the news.
And so I texted Joe and I was like,
is there any chance of doing it at your
studio?
And being the gentleman that he is,
he was like,
sure,
just come on by and we'll just type it,
even though he had to show his
yesterday.
So after those shows,
late at night,
Sam Harris comes over
and Hannibal buress is still here.
So send me,
it was about to call an uber and I said,
why don't you stick around?
Yeah,
we were drunk.
We drink so much whiskey.
The best decision you ever made,
inviting him to stay.
So Hannibal buress and Sam Harris and
Joe Rogan and I have an interesting
episode of my podcast,
which will come up.
So if you're listening to this now or
watching this now,
subscribe to a way that people live.
Just switch for we the people space
live.
You need the live and then when it drops
you will,
you will see it.
It was dining epic,
our long argument between Hannibal Burr
a drunk Hannibal burress and Sam Harris
regarding a statistics.
We'll just leave it at that.
Yeah,
you don't want to give him more
statistics that may or may not involve
black lives matter and police shootings,
police shootings,
and just the reality of police violence
versus the perceived reality of police
violence.
So arguing about the statistics rather
than the emotional.
That's right.
Connection and the difference.
And I mean what was interesting is how
we have conversations about things that
are so touchy,
right?
I mean,
part of the reason why I want to talk to
Sam and you on my podcast is because I
think it's important for us to find ways
to have the sorts of conversations that
you have in that Sam has and that
hopefully I have where there's not a lot
of,
uh,
kind of opinionated bloviating it's more
about actually trying to understand each
other,
actually trying to take each other at
face value,
not sticking,
you know,
what a sword in the sand and saying
like,
I can't believe that you offended me.
Or you know,
having tripwires that if someone
transgressed as that or says a certain
thing,
then all of a sudden you're going to
crank up the outrage machine.
So much of that,
so much of that.
So I wanted to talk to Sam and knew
about what,
how do we have conversations that are,
that are more reasonable.
But of course
you don't necessarily have a
conversation that reasonable when you're
drunk and emotionally sensitive.
A drunk Hannibal burress and says that
he's smarter than Sam Harris and smarter
than I think anyone.
Didn't he say anyone?
Ah,
he debates that he was smarter than Sam
Harris.
I mean,
Annabelle's a smart guy.
He must be successful and he's,
he's a compelling and good comic.
Just not smart enough to know that he
shouldn't say smart Sam Harris.
He was drunk,
really drunk,
and we kept drinking too.
You hit it.
Well,
you hold it like,
well,
I bounced back quick.
I'm healthy.
Yeah.
So I stopped drinking also.
So what you're implying exactly what I
said.
You heard me and,
uh,
about an hour before the end of our
potty of me and Hannibal,
I realize I was drunk.
So I backed off and he didn't play out
that he was pouring himself.
Huh?
How like half a half a wine glass of
whiskey?
Yup.
Yeah,
it was deep.
We went deep.
So,
uh,
he can't be held responsible folks.
Okay.